Transcriber: Rawda Mohamed
Gözden geçirme: Ali Eren Kayhan
Hareketsiz zaman, zamansız
hareket olur mu?
Şimdi sizlerle bu sorunun
cevabını arayacağız.
Öncelikli olarak hareket ve zaman
kelimelerini masaya yatıralım.
Hareket nedir?
Biraz düşünelim.
Bir fizik terimi bir tarihçi olarak
tarihçinin fizikle imtihanı olmasın,
hemen kitapları karıştırdım.
Bir cismin sabit bir noktaya göre yerinin
zamana karşı değişimidir.
Cevabını buldum.
Güzel, aklıma yattı.
Demek ki burada önemli olan hareket için
değişimin zamana karşı olması gerekiyor,
öyle mi?
Demek ki hareketin tanımında
zaman odak noktası.
Peki o zaman. Zaman nedir?
Biraz düşünelim.
Bazen öğrencilerime de böyle günlük
yaşamda çok kullandıkları
kelimeleri sorarım.
Mesela “çocuğum söyle bakalım olay nedir?”
derim.
“Olay olaydır.” derler.
Genelde böyle cevaplar gelir.
İşte zaman nedir? Zamandır.
Öğrencilerimi asla kınamıyorum.
Bakın koskoca Aziz Akgül sunusa,
zaman nedir dendiğinde verdiği cevap bu.
“Bana bu soruyu sorma saydınız.
Biliyordum da.
Madem sordunuz ve söylemem gerekiyor,
o zaman bilmiyorum.”
Ne güzel çıkmıştım işin içinden.
Ama biz öğretmenler bu kadar kolay
çıkamıyoruz işin içinden.
Zaman nedir?
Aristoteles bana yardım etti.
Diyor ki iki an arasında meydana
gelen harekettir.
Zaman.
Bu sefer de zamanın tanımında
odak noktası olarak neyi
aldım? Hareketi.
Demek ki zamansız hareket, hareketsiz
zaman olmazmış.
Bunu öğrendim.
Çok güzel. Tabii,
fizik terimleriyle yola çıkan bir tarihçi
olarak,
almazsam içim rahat etmezdi.
1940′ların önemli tarihçisi Paul Ricoeur
zamanın tanımını çok güzel yapmış.
Diyor ki Zaman nesnel olarak aslında
hiçbir şey değildir.
Bizdeki bir fikirden başka
bir şey değildir.
O halde zaman bir illüzyon mudur?
Evet.
İlk insanlar düşünün.
Bir tanesi sabah kalkıyor diyor ki
Bu kalktığımız saat yedi olsun.
Tarlada işe koyuldum, işbaşı .
Saat sekiz, Acıktım. Öğlen yemeğe.
Güneş tepede, saat on iki.
Tarlayı sürme işi bitti.
Akşam beş.
Televizyon yok,
bir şey yok değil mi?
Sekizde jumba yatak.
Bu şekilde bir gün değil zaman dilimi
oluşturmuşlar diye düşünüyorum.
Yazı yok, bir şey yok.
Biz insanlar, modern insanlar bugün
ilk insanların zamanı ortaya nasıl
çıkardığını düşünürken bazı zannetmelerden
ileri gitmek zorundayız.
Yani demem o ki, ilk insanlar
düşünsenize öyle bir dünyadalar ki
son derece aciz bir
varlık olarak pat ortaya çıkmışlar.
Etraflarında dönen bir dünya var.
Çok tehlikeli bir dünya.
Depremler, seller, büyük felaketler,
hep çok ciddi can güvenliği
problemi var insanın.
En azından bir şeyleri kontrol
edebilmek istiyor.
İşte bu da o etrafındaki soyut, kendinin
çok üstünde ve korku yaratan hareketi
algılamak, anlayabilmek, anlamlandırmak,
bilmek
hatta elle tutulur, gözle görünür bir hale
getirebilmek için zamanı icat ediyor.
Peki zamanı icat ediyoruz da yani
zaman bir illüzyon dedik.
Bizim ortaya çıkardığımız bir şey.
İşte diyorum ki, acaba biz zamanın esiri
miyiz?
Zamanın efendisi miyiz?
Tarih bize öyle şeyler gösteriyor ki,
örnekler.
Çok başarılı örnekler ve bir
o kadar da başarısız örnekler var.
Tabii ki ben bugün başarılardan
yürüyeceğim.
Tarih bize şunu göstermiş; her çağda
belli başlık görevler, ödevler var.
Bir insandan beklenen, seni bir
sonraki çağa taşıyacak olan
belli görevler, ödevler.
Ne yaparsanız mesela tarih öncesinde, ilk
çağda çok iyi mızrak kullanıp hayvan
anlayabiliyorsanız, sizi
bu durum götürür, bir sonraki çağa
taşıyabilir, ya da orta çağda
yeni çağda çok iyi
at binip kılıç kuş alıyorsanız bu sizi
yine bir sonraki çağa taşıyabilir.
Ama işte bizim bu yakın çağ
pek öyle değil di mi?
Yirmi birinci yüzyıl bizden ne bekliyor?
sorusunun cevabı evet
yirmi birinci yüzyılda bu esiri olunan
zamanın efendisi olmamız gerekiyor.
Başarı için, var olmak için
dünyada ve bir sonraki zamana
kendimizi aktarabilmemiz için.
Zamanı yöneten kazanır diyor
yirmi birinci yüzyıl.
Peki yirminci yüzyıla baktığım zaman
zamanını yöneten insanlara böyle bir
terim kullanıldığını gördüm.
Dahiler, zamanını yöneten insanlar,
kendi branşlarında,
kendi uzmanlık alanlarında
ne olursa olsun dahi olabilecek
düzeye erişiyorlar.
Mesela dahi.
Önce bir tanımını yapalım nedir dahi?
Zannediyorum alanında, branşında çığır
açan kişi.
Hem alanında uzmanlaşmış
hem de yeni bir şeyler, inovatif
bir bakış açısı değil mi?
Son dönemde böyle diyorlar getirerek yeni
bir çağ açmış, kendi branşında böyle
insanlara dahi diyoruz.
İlk aklımıza kim geldi?
Einstein, evet Einstein bir dahidir.
İşte zamanın göreceli kavramı
çok önemli bir kavram.
Eğer hastaysanız o beş dakika geçmiyor.
Ama çok mutlu bir anınızda o beş
dakika hemen akıp gidiyor.
Çok güzel bir teori ve kendi alanında
çığır açmış bir insan.
Evet dahi. Ancak yirmi birinci yüzyıl
bizden bunun daha fazlasını istiyor.
Evet biraz acımasızca galiba.
Ama madem zamanı kovalamak ve
hatta onu geçmek istiyoruz.
Biz onun efendisi olup onu
yönetmek istiyoruz.
Biraz daha fazlası olmamız lazım.
Aradım, buldum.
Bunun da bir terimi var gençler.
Diyor ki, polymat olman gerekiyor.
Yirmi birinci yüzyıl senden
polymat olmanı istiyor.
Neymiş bu polymat denilen?
Hemen diyor ki Yunanca polimatesten
poli bilirsiniz çoklu demek matta
matematikteki bilmek, öğrenmek.
Yani çok bilen, çok öğrenen kişi
Polymatter. Yani ilk çağ filozofları
gibi mesela. İlk çağda çok daha
fazla var polymat.
Son döneme yaklaştıkça sayıları
giderek azalmış.
“Neden acaba?“sını size bırakıyorum.
Mesela ilk çağ gibi dedik
polymatlar şöyle yaparlar.
Bir alanda evet uzmanlaşırlar
ancak başka bir alanda da
en az onun uzmanı
kadar yenilikler doğuracak
yetkinliğe sahip olurlar.
Hatta başka bir uzmanlık alanında da.
Mesela ilk çağ filozofları
öyle değil midir?
Bu filozof hem matematikçi, hem astronom,
hem fizikçi, hem kimyacı vs. değil mi?
O zaman ben öğrencilerime şöyle derdim Bu
tabiri fark etmeden önce, ya gençler işte
o dönemde her bilimin zaten içeriği
azıcık ve dolayısıyla insanlar.
Bir insan beş bilim dalına da yetebiliyor
bugün öyle mi canım derdim.
Bu tabiri öğrenene kadar meğersem
olabiliyormuş.
Sonra oturdum.
Bu konuşmayı hazırlarken nedense
kendime göre bir liste hazırla Duygu
ve her çağın
polymatıyla tanıştır, beni dinlemeye
gelen sizleri. Kimleri tanıştırayım?
Bu benim listem bu arada,
tamamen bana ait bir liste.
Sizin listeniz farklı olabilir.
Tanıyanlar nasıl çıkmış da olabilir?
Şu an ilk çağdan başlayacağım.
Bence ilk çağın polymatı Aristoteles.
Neden?
Çünkü hangi bilim dalının altına bir
baksanız temelinden Aristo çıkıyor.
Size el sallıyor, merhaba.
Bir fizikte çalışmak isterseniz Aristo,
matematik çalışmak isterseniz Aristo.
Felsefe, mantık çalışmak isterseniz
Onun temelinde yine Aristo.
O zaman tamam bu adam bir polymat
dedim koydum cebe.
Orta çağın polymatı
o dönem Avrupa’da
skolastik düşünce var.
Dinin boyunduruğundan insanlar.
Bilim, deney ve gözlem yasak.
O zaman dedim ki Doğu dünyasına bakalım.
Orada biraz daha modern bir medreseler
pozitif bilimlerle uğraşıyor o dönemde.
Bunlardan bir tanesiyle
devam edelim dedim.
Orta çağın polymatı bence Ömer Hayyam.
Neden? Çünkü çok önemli.
Ömer Hayyam’ı işte müzik veya edebiyat.
Bu bayilerini bilmeyenimiz
yoktur değil mi?
Muhteşem.
Ancak onu polymat yapan ve onu Doğu
dünyasından çok Batı dünyasına hayran
bırakan özelliği;
oluşturmuş olduğu takvim.
Celali Takvim.
Celali bir takvim.
Bu gün miladi takvimden çok daha
hassas bir zaman ölçen
takvimdir. Küçük örnekler vereceğim.
Mesela miladi takvime göre
bir güneş yılı ne kadar?
365 gün 6 saat.
Bunu şöyle yazıyorlar 365,25.
O 25 bir günün dörtte biri.
Yani 6 saat.
Ömer Hayyam diyor ki Hayır,
365 gün, 24 22 gündür.
Düşünebiliyor musun?
Bin de üç hata payı olduğunu
ortaya çıkartıyor.
Şimdi buradan bakıldığında binde 3 bir
kayıp insan ömrü için çok mevzu bahis
değilmiş gibi görünebilir ama 4 milyar
yaşında dünya için bence gayet büyük bir
kayıp olarak değerlendirilebilir.
Ömer Hayyam’ın polymat koltuğuna
oturtan bence bu oldu.
Oluşturmuş olduğu takvimin en
hassas takvim olması.
Geldik yeni çağın polymatına.
Leonardo da Vinci.
Birçoklarımız yirmi kadar veya yirmi
küsür tablosuyla tanırız onu.
Tabii ki resim alanında bir dahidir.
Geliştirmiş olduğu o yeni bakış açısıyla,
yeni bir takım hareketlerle de bir resime
bambaşka bir çığır açar.
Ancak o bir iki kalp çizimi vardır,
internetten bakabilirsiniz bir o kadar
ayrıntılı çizmiş ki bir tıpçı gibi
muhakkak kalbi alıp laboratuvar
ortamında incelemiş olmalı dersiniz.
Aynı embriyo çizimleri de o şekilde.
Muhakkak incelemiş olmalı.
Embriyoyu bu kadar ayrıntılı, bu
kadar detaylı çözebilmesi için.
Öte yandan bir şehir tasarlamış bir mimar
gibi daha birçok alanda çığır açmış.
Bence polymat koltuğunu hak etmiş.
Geldik yakın çağa, yakın çağın polymatı.
Bence Mustafa Kemal Atatürk. Neden?
Hepiniz ilk çağ sıralarından beri
Mustafa Kemal’in askeri ve siyasi
dehasına tanık oldunuz.
Uyguladığı hattı müdafaa stratejisi
dünyada tek bir örnek Kurtuluş Savaşı'nın
kazanılmasını sağladı.
Öte yandan yokluklar içinde Anadolu’dan
kendi başına dik durabilen, ekonomisi
kendi kendine yeten, bölgesinde lider
konumuna ulaşmış bir ülke yarattı.
Bu da yetmezmiş gibi bir de birçok
öğrenci gönderdi mesela yurt dışına.
O kadar farklı alanlarda ki, gönderdiği
öğrenciler. Filolog, arkeolog, tarihçi,
müzik dalıyla ilgilenenler ve bugün
önemsemediğimiz birçok bilim dalında
mesela etnograf, antropolog bunları
yurtdışına gönderdi.
O dönem Türkiyesinde, bu adamlara yurt
dışına gönderip para ayıracak bir bedel
ödeyeceksiniz değil mi?
Böyle bir imkan yoktu.
Vaad etti. Bu insanlar döndüler.
Türkiye'de büyük bir dönüşüm yarattılar.
Mustafa Kemal’in başarısının bence en
önemli sırrı, çok yönlü bir insan.
Evet, bir matematik ve geometri kitabı
yazacak kadar matematiğe geometriye hakim.
Batı musikisini sever ama Türk
musikisinin de makamlarını
bilecek kadar tanır.
Öte yandan dil, tarih, coğrafya,
antropoloji, arkeoloji birçok alanda
çığır açmış çalışmaların sahibi.
Bu kadar yeter mi
Atatürk’ü polymat seviyesinde görebilmem
için? Kesinlikle yeterli.
Peki biz bunun ne kadarının farkındayız?
Atatürk'ün yaptıklarını tabii
ki çok farkındayız.
Ancak ne kadarını hangi ölçüde devam
ettirebildik ve onun arzu ettiği muasır
medeniyet seviyesine ülkemizi
hangi ölçüde getirebildik?
Zamanın esiri mi olduk yoksa
zamanın efendisi mi?
Bu söz bence Atatürk için söylenmiş en
derin anlamlı ve bugün anlamamız gereken
sözlerden bir tanesi.
Fransız bir yazar söylemiş.
“Atatürk, yüce bir dağa benzer.
Bu dağın yüceliğini eteklerinde oturanlar
tam olarak anlayamaz.
Onun yüceliğini anlamak için bizim gibi
ona uzaktan bakmak gereklidir.”
Ne yazık ki öyle.
Bizler belki doğru tahlil edemediğimiz
için net olarak almamız gereken ödevi
görevi alıp zamanın efendisi
yapamıyoruz ülkemizi.
Ama umutsuz olduğumu da
lütfen zannetmeyin.
Sadece dün akşam dinlediğim bir haber beni
bütün insanlık adına mutlu ederken
düşündürmedi de değil. Elon Musk.
Ne yapmış biliyor musunuz?
İnsan beynine takılacak
bir çip geliştirmiş.
Felçli insanların telefon
kullanabilmelerini sağlıyor.
Düşünce gücüyle düşünerek telefonunuzu
kullanabiliyorsunuz.
Bu takılacak olan çipler. İşte bunu
düşündüğüm zaman biraz telaşa
kapılmadan değil.
Dünya nerede, nereye gidiyor,
biz yakalayabilecek miyiz?
Biz tabii ki siz gençlere çok güveniyoruz,
kendimize de güveniyoruz.
Birlikte olursak başarabiliriz
diye de düşünüyoruz.
Şimdi tabii ki son sözü Atatürk'e
bırakarak huzurunuzda ayrılacağım.
Atatürk diyor ki; “Yerinde sayıyorsan,
geriliyorsun demektir.
Lütfen ileri, daima ileri.”
Teşekkür ederim.
Konuşmasını yaptığı
için Duygu Hanıma teşekkür ediyoruz.
Ben teşekkür ederim.